I told you on Monday that 105 house Democrats
now publicly support and impeachment inquiry
against Donald Trump, that number has increased
and the House Democrats have now reached and
surpassed the 50% mark to get to an impeachment
inquiry.
The house. 435 members, half plus one is 218
the number of Democrats now supporting and
impeachment inquiry is at least one oh nine
exactly half of that to 18 and according to
some reports it's as high as 117 including
the support of former Republican congressman
Justin Amash, who we have talked about is
abandoning the Republican Party for very good
reasons that a m indicate his concern with
what's going on there. So remember, Republicans
are not needed to reach 50% plus one support
because Democrats took control of the house
in the 2018 midterms. Another one of the ways
in which that election was extremely important
and every election is important. Now there
are a few things that are continuing to hold
this number back. Why is there not more support
for an impeachment inquiry in the House of
Representatives? Number one, if Nancy Pelosi,
the democratic speaker of the House said,
yeah, it's time, it's time to start the impeachment
inquiry, that would instantly increase support
among Democrats in the House of Representatives.
Secondly, there are Democrats in red states
who are worried about the consequences in
their 2020 reelection campaigns. If they support
an impeachment inquiry that their constituents
don't like, I do not think that this is a
real issue. The power of incumbency is going
to be outdone by simply standing up for what
you believe in or let me kind of frame it
a different way. If a Republican can knock
out an incumbent Democrat simply by saying
the Democrat is bad because they wanted an
impeachment inquiry, that's not a Democrat
who has a very strong hold of their district
to begin with, so I don't buy that nonsense
for even a second. And then there's one other
important thing to remember, which is that
half of House Democrats or a little more now
publicly support and impeachment inquiry.
Of course there are more who support it privately,
but for different reasons have not yet decided
to go public.
It could be for the reasons I mentioned before,
it could be for reasons I haven't mentioned.
The number one oh nine is noteworthy or one
17 or whatever the number is. It's noteworthy
both for how large it is and for how small
it is. What I mean by that is on the one hand,
it's not common for half of the members of
one party in Congress to want to start an
impeachment inquiry against the president.
When Barack Obama was president, you didn't
have half of House Republicans wanting an
impeachment inquiry against them because it
wouldn't have made any sense. With George
W. Bush, you didn't have half of Democrats
wanting to start an impeachment inquiry against
George W. Bush and he did some really, really
bad things. So this is a very large number
in the sense that it's trouble for Donald
Trump, but there's another side to that. How
is it that only one oh nine or one 17 members
of congress are publicly foreign impeachment
inquiry?
Given everything that we have already learned,
all that to happen is Nancy Pelosi saying,
I believe we need to start an impeachment
inquiry. If she does that, it's over. It's
already unusual to see 109 or 117 break with
the public view of the speaker of the house
from their own party. If Pelosi comes around,
we will have an impeachment inquiry. In the
end, she should come around because it's the
right thing to do and it's her job. The only
good argument I have heard for not starting
an impeachment inquiry today is the idea that
starting an in six months might be more damaging
to Donald Trump, and I would be okay with
that. Short of that explanation, I don't see
any reason not to start an impeachment inquiry
immediately. And I want to hear from you about
it. Make sure that you're following the David
Pakman show on [inaudible]
Instagram at David Pakman show. And while
you're there, throw me a follow as well at
David Dot Pac, the David Pakman